the next part of this is how they are
going to use their radical positions to
govern over us i mean the art the irony
is again this decision put more power
back in individual people and states
hands but they are not really into that
they like when everything is controlled
from something above above us here is
vice president kamala harris trying to
figure out how they can fund abortion no
matter what and what about the idea of
financial resources
some form of voucher for travel child
care services other forms of support for
people for women seeking abortions in
states where it's not legal but they
just don't have the means to go
elsewhere i think you're asking a very
important point making a very important
point which is what are the details are
going to go into ensuring that women
have the ability to actually
travel
without impairment and we know that on
this issue women who have access to
resources will probably be far less
impacted by this decision than women who
don't have resources so this is
something that we are looking
okay so what's interesting so it's
something we are looking at now if the
federal
government
is not in charge of abortion but then
the federal government decides to fund
people having abortions it seems like we
have a problem there right why should
your federal tax dollars go to fund
someone's someone else's abortion as i
have said repeatedly if california and
new york and all the rich celebrities
that live there want to fund abortions
if all the democrats want to have
abortion parties and abortion
fundraisers so they can get all these
black and brown girls to come from these
scary red states and have abortions and
then maybe you get a cookie after and
then we send you back then i guess so be
it right because i am a states rights
person if individual people in certain
states want to raise money for other
people to come to their states to have
forces that's one thing but now that the
supreme court of the united states has
said this has nothing to do with the
federal government i don't see how the
federal government can use a dime of
anyone's money to move people
to have abortions in in states that will
keep abortion legally uh now
interestingly also let's contrast that
with that video that i showed you
earlier of joe biden in 1988 keep
government out of abortion so it seems
that joe biden of 1988 is at very uh
strange odds with joe biden of 2022 and
certainly uh with kamala harris of 2022
uh his own health and human services
secretary
xavier becerra
is also trying to figure out ways that
they can make sure that people are going
to still have abortions
how about the suggestion that's been
floated by senator elizabeth warren
about
carving out federal lands
for abortion providers is that possible
there are a number of conversations on
any number of options that can be out
there we will certainly take a close
look as we made a commitment uh some
time ago months ago as we were planning
for whatever might come from the supreme
court we will take a look at every
option to make sure a woman has access
to the care that she needs
we're not prepared to say what that
means yeah all those things have been uh
put on the table
man i mean i don't know how you can
describe this thing as anything other
than death cult
again that's within the context of you
knowing what my feelings are on abortion
are right knowing that there has to be
some wiggle room there and of course the
rights to privacy and individual rights
are important and all of those things
but these people want federal lands we
will have these special federal lands
where we will pay people to come and
have seven month abortions like it
really is psychotic that is what is so
important to them it is so important
that the state should have nothing to do
with a woman's right to make medical
decisions the same freaking people the
same people that just weeks ago wanted
everybody to be injected with their
experimental vaccine right that didn't
even work that's what we are up against
right now the the it's off the charts
hypocrisy and it's it's just so in your
face it's so brazen it's so in your face
that it's actually hard to believe and
what it's really showing you is that
they actually hate representative
democracy they hate that this experiment
allows for people to live differently
they're pretending that all of us on the
scary right or whatever you want to call
it are demanding that everyone bow to
their religion and everything else when
in fact they're just giving power back
their decentralizing power